you saw that flooded burning man we
talked about it a little bit yesterday
70 000 people trapped because as a
general rule again I don't want to read
too much into it necessarily it's
generally a good idea to avoid traveling
to the desert for week-long drug-fueled
bacchanalian orgies that culminate in
the worship of a giant fiery Idol I
would just avoid that I'm not saying
you're going to get flooded out every
time you do that but it it has been
known to happen once or twice so
what's the cause of the flooding
according to the view
Donald Trump this is one of the many
tragedies this this summer uh due to
climate change this is one of those
things
this is the one number one existential
problem it rained three months worth
over 24 hours but when I hear
Republicans say oh it's not man-made
it's not about fossil fuels you know
when Trump was President all of that
went up the fossil fuel usage went up
and the regulations to the planet please
don't vote for him I'm begging you get
him out of here he's so dangerous
droughts
climate change
floods
fire
that's climate change
freeze
it's climate change
you stubbed your toe this morning
getting out of bed that's climate change
the Liberals accuse us of worshiping
Donald Trump of being in a cult
Following the Leader of Donald Trump
I would never attribute the power of the
weather to Donald Trump I like the guy
obviously I admire him best president of
my lifetime
but I don't have such an outsized view
of his influence
that I attribute to him the powers of
lightning and thunder and rain in the
desert
people who attribute those god-like
powers to Donald Trump are entirely on
the left now speaking of God and burning
man Mike Lee
I just got to point out I've mentioned
it a number of times before Mike Lee is
just one of the best Senators we have
he's just one of the best politicians he
is
super smart guy he's extremely
principled he's
he comports himself in a responsible way
and is just all around a very serious
guy and
he just gets it man you know Mike Lee's
Twitter handle is based Mike Lee
and I I thought it was kind of a joke at
first I didn't actually think that it
was it was Mike but it is and
you know you think because he's buttoned
up and Mormon and a constitutional
lawyer and really polite and everything
that he's just gonna be a Wallflower or
something but he's not and especially on
social and cultural even religious
issues he digs down really deep and
doesn't doesn't back down so when the
news of burning man came out
uh Mike Lee just tweets out he goes this
is not healthy God's judgment is real
which is true fact check 100 True show
me the lie you can't do it
now what he was responding to by the way
it was not just news of the flooding it
was news of what was going on before the
flooding and this is a family show so I
can't I can't read much of this on the
air uh
this is a headline wildest Burning Man
events
no I actually can't read any of it it's
all just super super weird sex stuff
that involves like groups of men
standing around naked and whippings and
naked oil wrestling and hypnosis circles
and man I am cleaning this up so much
that you probably have no idea what I'm
talking about you can go read it at the
Daily Star
this is
really depraved decadent stuff and the
thing that's most striking about it is
not that weirdos will go to the desert
and do weird drugs and sex stuff
it's that according to the elite if you
go to this according to the elite if you
drive out to the the middle of the
desert and do a ton of drugs and have
all sorts of weird orgies with people of
both sexes and everything in between and
then worship a giant burning Idol and
then go home after nine days you are
cultured and sophisticated you're really
you're avant-garde you you want you
you're Progressive you're thinking ahead
of all those Rubes
and if you go to church you're in a cult
and if you vote for a republican you're
an occult you're a weirdo you're totally
crazy
right now head on over to hallow.com
Knowles it is clear that the left is
giving up their morals and any Common
Sense there is no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you are thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
improve overall well-being also you owe
prayer to the Lord your God so even if
it didn't benefit you you still ought to
do it and of course it does benefit you
hello is the number one Christian Prayer
app in the U.S it's helped a lot of
people to maintain a daily prayer
routine and it can help you too download
the app for free at hallow.com
you can set prayer reminders and track
your progress along the way if you're
not sure where to start check out father
Mike schmitz's Bible in a year it's my
absolute favorite podcast available on
the Hallow app for brief daily readings
and Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim Caviezel even some
world-class athletes
with hallow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions connect with others who
share your beliefs and values get a
sense of belonging support and Foster
some Community right now go to
hallow.com
Knowles get an exclusive three months
free three months absolutely free at
hello.com Knowles
hypnosis naked oil wrestling daily
whippings in the desert
posh
you know that's just what the elites do
that's just what we do
you remember
it was Dominic Strauss Khan
was that big Financial marketing muck
this was now we're going back like 20
years but it was the it was the first
one of these guys in my lifetime who was
one of the big you know the people at
the big institutions like the IMF or the
UN or the WTO or these big massive
institutions who got caught doing really
weird sex stuff
and and his defense was oh no I don't go
to that many orgies you know I know I
don't go to this man and then the story
came out during the hunter Biden
investigation that there's this really
Elite
sex club in La maybe it's in New York
too with movie stars and politicians and
all do you remember Madison cawthorne he
basically got run out of Congress for
blowing the whistle on eyes wide shot
parties in our nation's capital
you know the home of our sacred Temple
of democracy the most most pristine
light of democracy ever in the history
of the world and and then of course
there was Jeffrey Epstein when we found
out that
the supposedly conspiratorial Q Anon
whatever theory that the elites run this
underage sex ring is not only not a
conspiracy theory but they've got their
own Island and it involves not only
elected heads of state but also members
of the royal family and also huge
Business Leaders and
it's all it's all real it's it's
difficult for me to even wrap my head
around it now having seen all of the
evidence for years and years and years
now
I guess that's just the way it works in
this world because the devil is the
prince of this world and we struggle not
against flesh but against principalities
and powers and spiritual wickedness in
high places
and in that world we talked about a book
Yesterday by the Italian General Roberto
venachi called the world upside down in
that upside down world if you go do
weird bakhanaian drug orgy idol worship
stuff in the desert
you're you're normal it's like and if
you just have a normal family and you go
to church and you're crazy it's like the
monsters you remember the Monsters TV
show I'm really dating myself
as a millennial who watched reruns in
the 90s on Nick at night but in The
Munsters you got all these crazy
monsters who are in the family and this
one hot blonde girl and the hot blonde
girl thinks that she's ugly because her
environment is such that she's
surrounded by monsters all the time and
so her perception is that she's the
abnormal one she and that's that's how I
think us conservatives that's how we
feel now
I think am I crazy am I the crazy one
because I don't go to the orgies in the
desert Maybe
according to the wisdom of this world I
guess I am boy what a great clip that
was huh now before you go make sure you
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time